this is a production of cornell
university
thanks everyone for being here um so i'm
a master's phd student
which means that this presentation is
going to have elements of both
what i've done in my master's as well as
what i plan on doing in my phd and so
really this presentation is
a broad encapsulation of my entire
graduate school experience and i think
that
when designing a presentation that's so
broad
it helps by starting with what drives my
research interests and the most
important
moment in me as an agroecologist
was my high school senior project
where on a whim i decided to study the
importance of biodiversity
in natural and managed systems and so
the next two slides are going to be
slides from that presentation so i
didn't really
know much about biodiversity
but i realized that i wanted to have a
project which was on how
different people interacted with
wilderness
agriculture and urban areas and how
biodiversity influenced these
interactions
and i also realized that to learn more
about biodiversity
and answer my questions i wanted to
break up my
my project into four questions
so i started by asking what is
biodiversity and
and what are ecosystem services
second what's the importance of an
ecosystem service
third what are what are the current
trends in biodiversity and why should we
care
and then finally how can we promote
biodiversity
and i had a great time asking myself
these four questions
and so when i finished high school i
decided to study agriculture
and i chose to study agriculture
because i learned that agriculture
covers
about one-third of the world's uh land
area
and 66 of agricultural land
is dedicated to five crops so as someone
who
was interested in promoting biodiversity
i realized that agriculture has or at
least
sorry conventional agriculture has a
tremendous
um homogenization effect on biodiversity
and i also learned that a tremendous
amount of inputs
go into maintaining conventional
agricultural systems
so there's uh billions of pounds of
pesticides that are used annually
and and there are consequences to this
over-reliance on pesticides
including non-targets effects on
biodiversity
as well as effects on human health
across the world the main type of
pesticide used
are herbicides and so herbicides are a
class of pesticide
that is used to manage
plants or weeds and the consequence
of over-reliance on herbicides
has been the increase in cases in
herbicide resistance
and since the 1980s we've had a
pre-consistent
and steep increase in weeds that
are not as responsive or not responsive
at all to herbicide treatments
the increase in herbicide resistance is
particularly problematic
when taken into account with the fact
that the agrochemical sector
has not put out a new uh herbicide mode
of action
for the last 30 years so quite literally
farmers can't stay ahead of the
herbicide resistance curve
and in new york herbicide resistance is
a
real issue there are four weeds which
are
officially defined as herbicide
resistant
and their common ground cell smooth
pigweed common ragweed and common
lambsquarters
however there is reported herbicide
resistance
in horse weed tall water hemp and
polymer ammonium
and these are pretty common weeds in new
york and so the fact that there's
herbicide resistance in these species
shows that it's a real problem and it's
a real problem
here in our state
on the flip side of the coin uh a lot of
weed management
in farm systems and especially in
organic systems
is accomplished through tillage however
overuse of tillage drives erosion
in fact most erosion occurs on croplands
and is
due to tillage and erosion
is quite problematic to the
sustainability
of agriculture as about one-third of the
earth's arable land has been
lost to erosion in the last 40 years
okay and so compared to the average
natural area
erosion rates in agricultural settings
are one to two orders of magnitude
higher and so that's displayed in this
figure here where
the x-axis shows erosion rates
this band here is what's defined as the
acceptable rate by the usda
and we have agriculture compared to
three natural settings
and we can see that one agriculture has
pretty high erosion rates and that too
the median rate
of erosion in agriculture is higher than
what's acceptable by the usda
and so in response with a lot of the
problems with conventional weed
management two agroecologists
matt liekman and eric gallant proposed
the
many little hammers paradigm of weed
control
and the idea behind this approach is to
combine
tactics which are weakly effective when
applied in isolation
but can provide effective weed
suppression
and by spreading the burden of weed
management across several methods
a farmer can promote farm system
resilience
because their weed management program
isn't contingent upon the success
of one big hammer of weed control
like tillage or herbicides likewise
because each of these management
practices
are relatively weak in isolation
there is a reduced potential for the
development of weed resistance
because there is a less intense
selective pressure
on a wheat a weed species okay
so the many little hammers approach can
be
uh more sustainable in the long term
and another um interesting
emphasis of this approach is that
diverse weed management practices can be
synergistic
which means that when a lot of
weed management practices are applied
together their effect on the weed
community
may not necessarily be additive in fact
it can be
multiplicative or have interesting
interactions
and the use of ecological knowledge to
manage weeds
is called ecological weed management and
there are various mechanisms
by which ecological management can
reduce yield loss
and these are described by bastions and
he has
four graphs where yield loss is
on the y-axis the
density of weeds is on the primary
x-axis
and the number of weed seeds in the seed
bank is on the
secondary x-axis and the first
mechanism of weed control is reactive
weed control and this is quite a
conventional method
of managing meats it it is based upon
killing weed plants that have emerged
and so practices
like secondary tillage and hand weeding
kill weeds that have emerged to reduce
their density
and then reduce yield loss okay
a mechanism of ecological weed
management
is the reduction in the emergence of
weeds from the seed bank
and so practices like mulching can
reduce
weed seedling emergence rates okay
the third or the another mechanism of
ecological weed management
is reduced weed crop competition
and unlike the other two mechanisms the
idea here is not to
reduce yield loss by reducing
the density of weeds rather to reduce
yield loss by increasing crop tolerance
to any given density of weeds
and there are various we are various
crop management practices
which can accomplish this mechanism of
ecological weed management
for instance fertilization can be
modified
to change wheat crop competition
dynamics
so a farmer can band their fertility
across a crop row
to prioritize for killing fertilizing
the crop instead of the wheat
as they would if they were broadcast
fertilizing
a farmer can also select for more
competitive cultivars
or they can do inner cropping and
intercropping is the planting of
more than one crop plant on any given
area of land
and intercropping can affect resource
availability dynamics
and consequently affect wheat crop
competition
another mechanism of ecological weed
management is the reduction
of seed recruitment
into the seed bank and so this is any
practice
that that limits weed seed grain so for
instance
mowing uh before a weed sheds its seeds
would accomplish the reduction of the
weed seed bank
and so when i was learning about these
practices of ecological weed management
i became particularly drawn to the use
of
inner cropping as a mechanism to reduce
wheat crop competition
because remember my primary motive
in research is to promote biodiversity
in agricultural settings and so i
thought wow great
by having inner cropping we can reduce
reliance on conventional weed management
practices while also promoting
biodiversity and agriculture so
when i started my masters i knew that i
wanted to look for a project in
intercropping
and at this beginning phase
of my graduate program i went through
um a phase where i was consuming a lot
of theoretical literature
to to create the underpinning for my
masters
and i became very attached to niche
partitioning theory
and niche partitioning theory says that
planting
community diversity enables the
exploitation of more niches
okay and a niche is any range of
environmental conditions
in which an organism can live and the
way i think of niche partitioning theory
is by thinking of
siblings so if you have two siblings
which are very similar in age and
share very similar interests there might
be more potential for them to compete
conversely if you have two siblings
which differ in age and different
interests there's less potential for
them to be more competitive
and the same idea applies to plant
communities
where if you have a plant community of
very similar plants
they're likely to exploit the same
resources and be very competitive with
one another
conversely if you have a lot of
diversity in your plant community
especially functional diversity your
plants will be
using different resources and
consequently there is
less potential for competition
the application of niche partitioning
theory
into agriculture has been done by by
many scientists
but i was particularly drawn to the
resource pool diversity hypothesis
and this hypothesis was postulated by
rich smith
who's on my committee and matt ryan
who's
my advisor and the idea of the resource
pool diversity hypothesis
is that agricultural practices influence
the extent
to which niches are partitioned between
crops and weeds
and that the more diverse a management
system the less potential there is for
wheat crop competition
so the idea is if a farmer plants
the same crop year in and year out
they're likely to select for a weed
community that's very similar to their
crop
and consequently very competitive
against their crop
whereas if a farmer diversifies their
management system
through practices like crop rotation or
inner cropping or
varying their fertility and tillage
regimes
they will keep their weed and crop
community out of sync and consequently
there will be less intense
wheat crop competition and
an interesting research study um
that's that's kind of kind of related to
resource pool diversity hypothesis
was one that found that inner cropping
can reduce
the total weed biomass as well as
influence soil nutrient dynamics
relative to monocultures
okay another interpretation
or extension of niche partitioning
theory that i was very interested in
was the microbial mediated resource
hypothesis
and this hypothesis says that
rhizosphere soil microorganisms
can mediate plant resource availability
and a rhizosphere soil microorganism is
a microorganism that's associated to
plant foods
okay and so the idea here is that
diverse plant microbe relationships
can promote niche partition
and this research um is
or this hypothesis uh has interesting
contextualization
when taken into account with research
that has shown
that farm system management can affect
rhizosphere microbe communities
and so that's displayed in these two
plots
these two plots are non-metric
multi-dimensional scaling plots
which means that they're ordinations
okay so each of these points
shows an entire rhizospheric community
and
a is bacterial uh rhizospheric
communities
whereas b is fungal rhizosphere
communities
so the greater the distance between
points the more difference communities
are
okay and the color of these points uh
denotes the site from which the soil was
taken
whereas the shape of the points denotes
farm management system
and the finding of this paper was that
the primary method of separation
between rhizosphere communities was the
location
of which they were sampled however there
was
a significant effect of farm management
system
on the rhizospheric microbial
communities
and i think that's very well shown in
soil
fungal risosphere a soil fungal
rhizosphere communities and so at this
site we can see that there is
a clear separation in the organic and
conventional systems
so given all this past work
when i came to the drawing board and
decided to
formulate my master's project i decided
to ask
do soil nutrients and microbes mediate
inner crop diversity legacy effects on
competition
and a key word in my my question
is that i'm looking at legacy effects
okay i'm looking at
whether inner crop diversity has a
rotational effect or a carry-over effect
because as i mentioned before there's
past research that has already shown
that
inner crop diversity can affect wheat
crop competition
and soil nutrient dynamics and that
broadly
farm system management can affect soil
rhizospheric microorganisms
so i wanted to see whether these effects
had a legacy
on wheat crop competition
and given that my work was was based off
of niche partitioning theory
i decided that my hypothesis would be
that weed cop competition
would be greater in soils from lower
compared with higher diversity
treatments
okay so today
for this presentation i'm going to share
the results of an experiment which were
recently published
and this was a greenhouse uh
weed crop competition experiment
and i was very fortunate in that
i was able to answer my questions of
inner crop diversity legacy effects on
wheat crop
competition by taking advantage of a
field experiment
that was managed by a grad student in my
lab
and by the findlay from 2016 to 2019
and this experiment had four diversity
treatments
in annual and perennial forage systems
okay and
this experiment was replicated in york
vermont and new hampshire and by
different
diversity treatments i mean that there
are different levels of diversity
okay so the low diversity treatment
was a one variety one species
monoculture
there was a pond-specific diversity
treatment
which had four varieties of one species
a heterospecific treatment which had
four species
and each of these species there was only
one variety of the species
and then finally there was a high
diversity treatment which had
four species and each of these species
there was four varieties
of these species carson okay and so one
important um note that i just want to
point out now because it's gonna
affect the my interpretation of the
results is that
notice that the treatments are all based
in a crop so the perennials are all
based in alfalfa
so in the low and con specific treatment
you only have alfalfa
whereas in the hetero and high specific
treatments you have
alfalfa and the introduction of
perennial grasses
and the same goes with triticale and
sorghum sedan grass in the winter and
summer annuals
okay
so for the greenhouse experiment i
sampled soils
from the new york site in 2018 during
this diversity conditioning phase
and i tested wheat crop competition
in a greenhouse experiment and i tested
the effects
of soil nutrients and microbes by having
three diversity or three greenhouse
treatments
i had a field soil treatment which was
50 biologically active field soil
to 50 sterile potting mix
i had an inoculated treatment which was
five percent
biologically active field soil and 95
sterile potting mix and then i had
an inert treatment which was a 100
sterile potting mix control
and the idea here was that the field
soil treatment
would have both the nutrient and
microbial legacies
of the inner crop diversity treatments
whereas the inoculated soil treatment
would attempt to minimize
soil nutrient differences while
maintaining unique microbial communities
and the reason i chose this ratio and
the reason we believe that
this is possible is that it follows the
methodology of plant soil feedback
experiments
and plant soil feedback experiments
attempt to test
the functional effect of soil microbes
on plant growth and they try to
ideally minimize nutrient differences
between soils so it's a rough but a
contemporary technique
so the way i tested weed crop
competition
was by growing a density gradient
of weeds across the four diversity
treatments
so i grow i grew zero to six common
lambs quarter weed plants
and one sword and sedan grass plant in
all of these ponds
okay and so i had the four diversity
conditional treatments that were present
in the field in
annual and perennial systems and i had
my
different weed densities and then i had
this
in the field and inoculated greenhouse
treatments
okay the field treatment being soil
nutrient and microbes
the inoculated soil treatment being
minimizing soil nutrients and trying to
maintain
microbial effects and then i had my
inert control
and by seeing the reduction in the crop
biomass
as a function of increasing weed density
in each of these diversity treatments
i was able to model crop weed
competition
through competition curves
another thing i was able to do was by
comparing
the biomass of a crop in the inoculated
to inert soil i was able to quantify
plant soil feedbacks
and plant soil feedbacks are the
relationship between
plants and their associated microbial
communities
and so for instance this would be an
example of a highly negative plant soil
feedback
because the plant growing in the
inoculated soil
is much smaller than in the 100
sterile inert soil okay
and so in this case this would indicate
that the soil has
a net pathogen pathogenic effect
on crop growth
so uh this next slide is going to show
you the
the results of my wheat crop competition
experiment
um but before i do that i want to dig
into
what composed my competition curves so
my competition curves were two parameter
models
the first parameter was a naught and the
a naught parameter
basically reflects the y-intercept
and consequently it shows yield
potential
right it shows how much the crop can
yield in the absence of weeds
the iw parameter is a the shape
parameter of these curves and
consequently it's the competition
coefficient
because the higher the iw term the
steeper this
initial slope in the curve and
consequently
the more intense speed crop competition
okay
and so just so we clarify crop biomass
is on the y-axis
v biomass will always be on the x-axis
okay and i compared curves through
f-tests
so my f-tests will
always be across diversity treatments
so remember these are the four diversity
treatments high to low
and this is the field soil treatment of
the greenhouse
in the annual system okay
and so these letters denote pairwise
comparisons
which will always be down the column
across diversity treatments
so this is the full figure all right
and it's it's a lot to digest so
if you focus in on the competition
curves which are statistically different
there are two interesting conclusions to
this competition
study and they apply to the annual and
perennial systems
so the first conclusion in the annual
system
we found that wheat crop competition was
stronger in soils with a greater crop
diversity legacy
and so this is opposing uh my hypothesis
um you know we did see a diversity
effect but in these soils
was the opposite effect than what we
were expecting
and so let's dig into this so so these
two curves are statistically different
and i feel confident in saying that
competition
was more intense in the heterospecific
treatment than the con specific
treatment
because the iw parameter which is this
initial slope term is higher in the high
diversity treatment than the low
diversity treatment
and the same go sorry the same goes for
in the inoculated soil treatments
at the same time the a naught parameter
here
is the same or very similar so
the conclusion here is that these curves
are statistically different
because of differences in wheat crop
competition intensity
okay so that's why i feel good about
this first conclusion
in the perennial soils the iw parameter
is also higher in the high diversity
treatment compared to
the lower diversity treatments with
statistically different curves
however there is considerable variation
in the a naught parameter which is the
y-intercept term so here the differences
between
curves may be driven by crop yields
potential
so i can't i can't confidently say that
crop crop weed or wheat crop competition
was higher in the high diversity
treatment
but if we look at crop yields potential
there is a second set of results which
are really exciting and interesting
so this figure shows crop yields
potential
so this is the yield of the greenhouse
crop in the absence of weeds
okay the x-axis
is the four diversity treatments
the annual and perennial systems
this is the field treatment in the
greenhouse
so both nutrients and microbes and this
is the inoculated
treatment okay so this attempts to
minimize nutrient differences while
maintaining microbial effects
and we can see that as i explained in
the figure before
the annual system has no differences
in yield potential
so that was the the no differences in
the a naught parameter
so that makes sense but in the perennial
system
we can see that there is an increase in
crop yields potential
with diversity legacy in the field
treatment
and a decrease in crop yields potential
in cross diversity treatments in the
inoculated soil treatment
so this is a very interesting and
exciting result i think
and to contextualize this result i think
we can draw upon the biomass of crops
that were growing
during the conditioning phase right
before i sampled my soil
so this figure here shows
the biomass of grass in red bars
and legume and blue bar crops right
before i sampled my soil
and this figure shows plant soil
feedback values
so notice that all of these values are
negative so it's basically
how pathogenic soils were
and again in the annual soils there were
no differences
in the biomass of conditioning crops and
all of the conditioning crops
were grasses likewise there were no
differences
in plant soil feedback values so
again crop yield potential in the annual
system no results
but if we focus on the perennial system
here the story gets really interesting
so let's explain what was going on in
the conditioning phase
remember how i told you that the
perennials were
based in alfalfa so you can see that
the low and con specific treatments
only have legume biomass however
as the experimental design called for
there was an introduction
of perennial grasses and the hetero and
high specific
treatments okay and there's a
significant
decrease in legume biomass
into high diversity treatment compared
to the low diversity treatment
and i think that these differences in in
the crops that we're growing during the
conditioning phase
could very well explain the results of
crop yield potential
in the greenhouse experiment so first
let's start with the inoculated soil
treatment
where crop yield potential decreases
with conditioning diversity
so remember the inoculated soil
treatment is attempting to look at
only microbial effects and there's
research
that shows that rotational diversity
will have a large influence
on the pathogen load of soils or the
plant soil feedbacks of these soils
wherein
if you rotate a
a grass system to a grass system it will
have much more negative
plant soil feedbacks than if you rotate
a grass system
to a legume system or grass or legume
crop
and remember that the crop that i was
growing in the greenhouse
was a grass so my
interpretation of the decrease in crop
yield potential
with conditioning diversity is that the
presence of a grass legacy
right before we had sampled soils
resulted in more pathogens
in the hetero and high specific hetero
and high diversity treatments and this
is affirmed
by my plant soil feedback study which
finds that there is a decrease
in plant soil feedback value as a
function of conditioning diversity
which is indicating that these microbes
were having
a net a greater net positive net
negative effect as a function of
conditioning diversity
for the field soil treatments okay here
are the soil treatments that have both
nutrient and microbial legacies
i think that the way we manage our crops
before soil sampling
explain these results remember
the experiment is trying to mimic a
forage crop system okay and so we were
cutting and removing the herbage
from the system multiple times a season
and there is research that shows that
multiple cuts
and removals of alfalfa urbita can
reduce soil nitrogen availability
whereas multiple cuts and remove or
multiple cuts
of perennial grasses can increase
root exudation and increase nutrient
cycling
so i think that the presence of a
perennial grass
legacy uh in that higher diversity
treatments
might have contributed to the higher
crop yield potential
in the field soil treatment so
the conclusions of this experiment that
i did for my masters
were that one crop diversity can have a
legacy
effect on wheat crop competition
and that too soil micro communities can
create crop diversity legacy effects
and perhaps have an independent
and potentially opposing effect on crop
yield potential
compared to soil nutrient microbes and
soil microbe and nutrient legacies and
so that was the figure that i
just showed you with the opposing trends
so this this was my my masters where i
was looking at
ecological weed management through inner
cropping
um and and there's multiple projects but
that was the
underlying theme of my masters
and in my phd i'm going to continue to
look at ecological weed management
but i'm looking at multiple mechanisms
of ecological lead
management i'm not just looking at wheat
crop competition
and also all of my experiments are going
to be focused
on a reduced till organic system
and i'm looking at two pathways to
reduce tillage
i'm looking at a roller crimp system
which is a system that rolls a cover
crop
with a very heavy roller to terminate
the cover crop and create
a mulch and then seeds a cash crop
directly
into that rolled mulch and i'm
also looking at reducing tillage through
perennial grains
so these are crops that stay in the soil
for multiple years and i have
four big experiments planned for my phd
the first experiment is looking at
cereal rye
and soybean based population weed
suppression
and the questions here are well how does
the low nitrogen environment
that's fostered by the decomposition of
cory
when it's rolled in a mulch system
affect wheat suppression and i
also want to see whether light
interception from
a increased soybean density i want to
see whether that promotes
wheat suppression and because i'm
looking at two tactics here
i also want to see whether a low
nitrogen environment
and a high soybean seeding population
have a synergistic effect
on wheat suppression
my second experiment is also in a
roller crimped cereal rye soybean
system but here what i'm varying
is the biomass of cereal rye and i want
to see how
different biomass of cori affects weeded
emergence from the seed bank
another thing i'm doing in this project
is i'm looking at the functional
diversity of the weed community
so i want to see how different biomass
treatments of steroid
will affect weed functional traits
and then the third and perhaps biggest
experiment of my phd is a broad
assessment of the compatibility of cover
and cash crops for organic no-till and
so here i'm seeing a whole host of
winter and summer cover crops and how
they roll for
winter and summer cash crops so there's
various
sub experiments or research
priorities in this this experiment
and so the first is just broadly seeing
the wheat suppressive abilities
of several winter and summer cover crops
compared to a tilt control
the second research priority is seeing
how cash crops emerge
in these uh rolled cover crop systems
um and then the third and perhaps most
theoretical uh question in this
experiment
is assessing how uh weed suppression
is driven by the mulch of a rolled cover
crop
versus the presence of wheat or of sorry
of roots in the system so remember that
unlike a conventional annual system
where there is primary tillage
uh you know at maybe many times a season
uh and the the rapid
decomposition of cover crop roots the
idea here is that the cover crop roots
stay undisturbed so i want to see how
the mulch versus roots
of a rolled copper crop impact
wheat suppression and finally
the last uh emphasis or last
project in my phd is testing for
synergism
between weed management tactics in
establishment near korenza
and kernsa is an emerging perennial
grain crop
with major corporate investments so
companies like patagonia provisioning
and general mills
have invested in this grain however one
of the
uh main issues with kurenza is
uh getting it to establish well and
and uh within that establishment year
currency is very
a very poor competitor against weeds so
what i want to do is i want to see
whether there's
a positive interaction between various
mechanical
and biological lead management practices
so these are the four projects of my phd
and today i've i've shared a lot
and first of all i would like to thank
uh ms tranel who was that high school
english teacher
um who gave me the
intellectual space to to do what i
wanted
i think this is a testament if anything
this project in
my grad school is a testament for
the importance of giving young people
intellectual creativity
and i also want to thank and by the
finley chris pelzer sandra weyman
and all the research assistants and
everyone associated to the lab
for helping me create these ideas
and get the work done um these people
have been
great help and great friends so with
that
um i'm done and uh yeah i'll open it up
for questions all right
nice job booty um
not sure i can see any other questions
but
you can feel free to unmute yourself if
you um have a question there is one
question in the chat from from ruby
i could read that to you or if you want
to look at it yourself um
it's basically uh asking about the
connection and interaction with
natural farming both korean and japanese
natural farming and whether or not
you'd been thinking about that um that
type of approach
um ruby says that there's purposeful
isolation of indigenous microorganism
communities
uh which are diluted and applied to crop
systems to provide inoculation of
microbe
of beneficial microbes and
she was wondering if you have any
knowledge of people
using these practices for weed
management
yeah so i'm not particularly
knowledgeable about
korean or japanese natural agricultural
practices
so so i don't know too much about those
systems
but what i do know is that there is
research
uh looking at how
inoculation with different microbial
communities
affects speed crop competition and
i am not looking at how i i've never
done a project where i've purposely
inoculated a cropping system with a
soil or microbial community
but i know people who do do that
i think it is a very interesting and
exciting
uh experimental uh avenue
i think it this is this is very
like my personal opinion here i think
that the
um i question
how how successful
application of microbial inoculum
is in a field setting where there's a
whole host of microbial community
already present
and which will compete with that
microbial community i wonder how
how establishment of that microbial
community will work
in a field versus greenhouse setting so
i think that's a
that's a potential limitation that i can
imagine
but i do know people who research that
um and will probably know
much more so that those are my opinions
all right so um we have another uh
question from chat and um uh ben was
asking how
how do you sterilize soil how did you
sterilize your soil hoodie
yeah that's a great question ben um so
a lot of thought went into that and and
it's impossible to truly have
a completely sterile solution but my
potting mix
was um a 60 vermiculite
to 40 triple washed sand
solution so vermiculite and sand are
both
firstly fairly inert um materials
okay so we weren't using some uh
greenhouse potting mix
which has you know a lot of
incorporation of
matter and then what we did is we
autoclaved
that potting mix and we autoclaved it
and then
immediately used it in the greenhouse
experiment of course
a greenhouse by definition is not a
sterile environment
so so um that uh
there are system limitations but um
all plant soil feedback many major plant
soil feedback experiments
are done in this greenhouse setting and
so the
the responses are at least strong enough
to see differences
in microbial functional effects from
crops
yeah thanks eddie so um jeff had a
question jeff liberdon was asking um
if you could elaborate on what some
practical applications might be from
your
master's research findings so
yeah so and i also see that brian brown
asked that question
and i think that's a really really good
question
right um especially doing agroecology
and you know working with
a applied system i think a really
interesting finding to my work is that
while my hypothesis
that diversity legacy effects
would produce less intense wheat crop
competition wasn't upheld
i found that rotational diversity did
affect
property competition or at least an
affected crop yield potential
so i think that the functional
implications
or applied implications of my work is
that i would tell a farmer
look like you can affect crop weed
competition
at least crop food competition curves
through rotational diversity
so i would emphasize the importance of
having a rotation
that has diverse crops right to not
rotate a grass to a grass or a legume to
a legume
so i think that is an interesting
implication of
this master's work thanks judy there are
a couple more questions here
um i'm not sure if you could read them
or if you'd like me to continue
um i can read them so uh andy asks
um uh i mentioned characterizing changes
in weed functional traits
and i was wondering how i would do this
so this is something that i'm really
excited about and
um i would be doing with stefan cordon
france
the idea here is to um
there are databases that that have
descriptions
of um various uh
functional traits in a weed community so
for instance
um it describes like root length or root
structure
or average leaf size
and the idea here is that i would input
all of these data
and be able to create some sort of
distance matrix
between the weeds in my community so be
very similar to the idea of
non-metric multi-dimensional squaring on
just the biomass of the community
but instead of looking at that i'm
looking at the uh
like the relevance or the presence of
certain functional traits and then
applying some sort of multivariate
technique
like a perminova to analyze whether
there's significant differences
so uh ashley asks what size pots i used
um i think they were half gallon pots
they were like
actually they're a little bigger like
this like this um
in so that's the size i used like half
gallon to one gallon
for this master's experiment when i was
at montana state
i used smaller pots i probably used a
quarter gallon
pot so there is variation in pot size
for plant soil feedback experiments
essentially what i wanted is i wanted to
make sure
one one important thing perhaps more
important than pot size
is making sure that you are trying to
keep the distance between your crop
and the weeds in this experiment
relatively standard so i didn't want to
have
one pot where all my weeds were like an
inch away
and another pot where all my weeds were
like you know six inches away
so that's perhaps more important
um ruby asks
um a very good question uh in terms of
standardizing soil nutrients
uh how did i do that so
basically it was by using different
ratios of biologically active field soil
to a sterile potting mix so
in the nutrient plus microbes soil i was
using
50 50 mix and in the
inoculated soil which is how i tested
plant soil feedbacks i was using a 5 to
95
mix and and this seems like a kind of a
coarse method but there have been
um methodological studies that have
assessed whether or not one you can
quantify microbial functional effects on
plant growth with this ratio and and to
how much of a confounding effect there
are about um
crop nutrients and the answer is you
this is a successful uh and
appropriate technique to use so i hope
that helps
um so people feel free to
unmute yourself too and um talk to me
talk to the people but um so anne asks
uh can you speak to what kind of farmer
may have used
uh practices in the last four
experiments you presented
where uh are your field experiments
located
and so um the
farmers that use my experiment are are
so this is a forage crop system um and
forages are very common
in new york and and the northeast
this experiment the diversity experiment
that
i was sampling from and and you you
managed really well for 2016 to 2019
was was replicated in new york
vermont and new hampshire and and it
attempted to use common forage crops
in all three of um hi
people um no the the
four experiments that you presented at
the end
oh yeah yeah i know about my stuff
yeah yeah i i just thought you wanted me
to
reiterate the fire so so yes these four
experiments
are there's um
they there's always going to be a
replication
near ithaca but
we have a large collaboration
with the farm hub which is in the hudson
valley
and so a lot of these experiments are
going to be replicated there as well
the cori biomass study was has already
been collected
that was years ago and i believe that
was here but i'm not sure
um and farmers who could use a
rotational no-till are farmers who are
seeking to reduce
typically organic farmers who are
typically are trying to
reduce tillage so say that you're an
organic farmer who has terrible tillage
issues
you might be interested in using rolled
cover crop system
also the rolled cover crop research is
there's also quite a bit of that being
done in conventional systems
so it's not out of the question that um
if i present this work at a farmer
meeting a conventional farmer would also
be interested
in assessing how different rolled cover
crops and cash crops
function so i think i think that it's
yeah it could be good yes so
andy brings up a very good point uh
which is on
characterizing the plasticity of
functional traits
uh as influenced by the competitive
environment and
i agree there um yes
there there is a we know when i'm out in
the field i do observe that there is
that plasticity
um i imagine that this
is in some way a follow-up question to
my
uh my proposal to study read functional
traits
um by using a uh
a database and and the answer to that is
that
you know um when doing that project i
would have to be very careful
to uh ensure that i was comparing
functional traits which are
um broad enough that that they would
continue to apply
in in different competitive environments
so for instance just broadly
thinking about root structure uh instead
of something as
specific as leaf area which i believe i
i might have given an example of
um so so yeah that's um
yeah but but that's a great point and uh
yeah i think there
there needs to be some interesting
research done in that area
so we are over time now it's 1 35
so i think um a great job i think we
can let people go here people that need
to leave
thanks for attending the seminar today
i believe woody will stay on for a few
minutes and we'll be available to answer
additional questions
but certainly if you need to leave we
understand and thanks for participating
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu